Bonjour!
-Bonjour! Quel jour merveilleux!
-T'as l'air en forme mais merci de me laisser
faire mon introduction...
-Mais tu comprends pas? On va parler du
XVe siècle aujourd'hui! C'est ma période!
Enfin!
-Ah, je vois, un épisode au XIXe siècle
et rien ne va plus. Sache que déjà on ne
va pas parler que du XVe siècle aujourd'hui
mais qu'on ira du XVe au XVIIe siècle et
que je referai très certainement à l'avenir
des épisodes sur le XIXe, le haut Moyen-Âge,
l'Antiquité, et si ça te plaît pas tu peux
aussi rentrer chez toi.
-Bienvenue dans cet épisode sur la chasse
aux sorcières!
-Eh, mais c'est ma phrase ça!
-Générique!
Cette vidéo peut se regarder toute seule
mais vient conclure une série de vidéos
sur le thème de la sorcellerie. Dans mon
épisode 12 sur l'Inquisition, nous l'avions
déjà abordée rapidement en restant du point
de vue des Inquisiteurs en France et de comment
ils menaient leurs procès.
Dans mon épisode 2 des créatrices du Tube,
j'ai présenté le déroulement imaginaire
du sabbat avec plein de jolies images.
Terminons donc ce triptyque avec du lourd:
la chasse aux sorcières, où se déroulait-elle,
qui étaient ces femmes et pourquoi, pourquoi
un truc pareil a-t-il eu lieu?
L'existence des sorcières est reconnue par
l’Église par la bulle Summis desiderantes
affectibus de 1484. Avant ça, les sorcières
avaient déjà été mentionnées par Saint
Augustin au IXe siècle, et par des théoriciens
du XIVe siècle qui réfléchissaient sur
les comportements hérétiques, lesquels tolérer,
lesquels condamner...
-S'il y avait un démon dans l'histoire, globalement,
c'était condamné.
-En 1486 est rédigé le célèbre Malleus
Maleficarum, le Marteau des Sorcières, par
deux membres de l'Inquisition allemands qui
y expliquent ce que sont les sorcières, pourquoi
ce sont surtout des femmes... Le tout afin
de justifier les débuts de la chasse aux
sorcières par leurs collègues et eux-même.
C'est un grand succès littéraire, tiré
à 30 000 exemplaires, même si en cette fin
du XVe siècle les persécutions envers les
sorcières commencent doucement: elles sont
surtout importantes au XVIe siècle.
En effet, durant la fin du XVe siècle les
procès de sorcellerie ne concernent pas plus
d'une cinquantaine de cas par an et par pays.
On les retrouve en Suisse et en Savoie, et
aussi à la frontière entre la France et
l'empire Germanique, ce qui s'explique par
le climat religieux dans cette zone.
-Et puis à cette époque là on accuse juste
les sorcières de maleficum, c'est à dire
de pratiques magiques, et on ne parle pas
encore de sorcellerie démoniaque.
Durant les deux premiers tiers du XVIe siècle,
les poursuites restent faible. Les ouvrages
comme le Malleus Maleficarum ne sont pas réédités,
et à ce moment là la mode est à la poursuite
des bouteurs de peste: les petits malins
qui propagent la peste!
Des lois apparaissent toutefois à l'encontre
de la sorcellerie: en 1532, Charles Quint
crée pour les Pays-Bas la Constitution criminalis
Carolina, une législation impériale sur
la magie et la sorcellerie. D'autres lois
répressives apparaissent en Europe à mesure
que de nouveaux traités de théologie sont
publiés.
Parce que vers 1580, ça redémarre: en
France le magistrat Jean Bodin écrit un traité
qui explique le sabbat, les crimes des sorcières
etc, et au total en Europe une trentaine de
traités sont rédigés à la fin du XVIe
siècle, par des théologiens et même par
le roi d’Écosse Jacques VI.
Dans la vision du début du XVIe siècle,
la chasse aux sorcières est un moyen d'affirmer
la puissance royale puisqu'elle intervient
contre Satan, ce sagouin qui pousse les femmes
à renverser l'ordre.
Les procès commencent donc en Écosse vers
1590, dans l'empire Germanique et en Scandinavie
au début du XVIIe siècle... Il existe des
épicentres de la chasse aux sorcières:
la Suisse, la France, les Pays-Bas et l'empire
Germanique.
Mais on retrouve aussi des procès en Autriche,
Belgique, Estonie-Livonie, Danemark, Finlande,
Hongrie, Islande, Luxembourg, Norvège, Pologne
et Suède.
A l'inverse les pays où on en retrouve très
peu sont l'Italie, où ils ne donnent pas
lieu à des exécutions, le Portugal, la Russie
et l'Espagne.
On a souvent le stéréotype de femmes vieilles
et vivant en marginales, qui porterait la
marque du diable, pratiquerait le sabbat et
lancerait des maléfices à l'encontre des
hommes et des bêtes.
-Forcément les sorcières sont vieilles,
parce que les vieilles c'est hyper mystérieux,
ça fait penser à la mort un peu, et donc
au diable, par extension... Non?
-Non mais y'a que vous que ça fait fantasmer
les vieux.
-Dans la réalité, qui sont ces personnes?
Dans la plupart des cas, ce sont bien des
femmes, elles représentent environ 80% des
personnes jugées, le reste étant des hommes
ou des enfants. On trouve une exception en
Russie, en Finlande et en Estonie, où le
taux de femmes n'est que de 40 à 50%.
Pour ce qui est de leur situation, elles sont
majoritairement paysannes: 80% des sorcières
sont issues de la population rurale, les villes
sont peu concernées par ces chasses aux sorcières
et ne la pratiquent qu'occasionnellement.
On a par exemple un cas à Aix en Provence
en 1611.
La plupart sont mariées: sur 100 cas en
Franche-Comté de 1434 à 1667, on compte
17 veuves, 27 célibataires et 56 femmes mariées.
Pourquoi ces femmes étaient-elles accusées?
La plupart du temps, elles étaient dénoncées
par des proches, voire par leurs enfants.
Il y a eu des cas d'enfants sorciers en Europe,
mais la plupart du temps ceux-ci jouaient
le rôle de dénonciateur, accusant leurs
parents ou leur mamie.
En 1671, dans la région du lac Siljan, au
nord de Stockholm, ce sont des enfants âgés
de 5 à 9 ans qui accusent leur famille de
participer au sabbat.
-Attendez, une fois ma mère m'a dit: «Si
t'es pas sage avec tes parents, t'iras pas
à la Saint-Jean». Bah j'y ai pensé hein,
une petite accusation et j'étais sûre de
faire la fête.
-Parfois les paysans se lançaient eux-même
dans la chasse aux sorcières, dans des périodes
de panique où tout le monde s'entre-accusait.
C'est comme ça qu'à Logrono en Espagne en
1610 ont lieu six exécutions pour sorcellerie.
Suite à ça c'est la grosse psychose, tout
le monde accuse tout le monde, des paysans
torturent eux-même des suspects... Au final
1777 personnes sont accusées, dont 1384 enfants,
les juges classent l'affaire en disant que
la sorcellerie disparaîtra si on arrête
d'en faire la publicité, ça va bien, on
se calme.
-C'est vrai que dans les campagnes c'était
un peu la psychose parfois. Il y a une histoire
de Philippe de Vigneulles qui raconte ceci:
un prêcheur arrive dans un village et il
demande aux villageois de baiser les reliques
qu'il se trimballait sauf les sorciers et
les sorcières, il leur interdit! Du coup
tout le monde s'empresse de le faire, de peur
d'être accusé de sorcellerie. Ils sont cons,
ces villageois.
-Parfois des catastrophes naturelles comme
des épisodes de famine ou de peste accélèrent
la chasse aux sorcières, mais dans la plupart
des cas les procès ont lieux en temps de
paix: en temps de guerre, les juges avaient
un peu plus peur de circuler entre les villages.
Durant les procès, comme les accusées étaient
souvent des pécores, elles n'osaient pas
trop la ramener. Les procès-verbaux nous
montrent qu'on leur posait des questions souvent
personnelles, très détaillées, tirées
des traités démonologiques et de ce qu'avaient
raconté les témoins. Les accusées étaient
parfois confrontés avec les témoins, torturés,
on recherchait sur leur corps la marque du
diable... Au début elles avaient tendance
à répondre juste par oui ou par non, puis
quand elles commençaient à lâcher psychologiquement
leurs réponses devenaient beaucoup plus détaillées,
dans le sens de ce que voulaient entendre
les juges.
Les accusées avaient aussi intérêt à se
montrer dociles, parce qu'ainsi elles pouvaient
espérer un retentum:
-Elles sont toujours condamnées au bûcher,
mais le bourreau les étrangle discrètement
dès que les flammes sont asses hautes pour
le cacher afin d'abréger leurs souffrances.
C'est très généreux.
-D'autres accusées pouvaient craindre d'être
des sorcières sans le savoir et culpabiliser.
Beaucoup parlaient immédiatement, ou tentaient
de se suicider pour éviter la torture.
Les procès visaient aussi à trouver des
complices, et là c'était l'hécatombe. En
1597, une accusée dénonce par exemple 19
personnes à elle toute seule. Le club de
sorcellerie de son village devait être costaud.
Le plus glauque dans l'histoire est que la
plupart des dénonciations par des condamnées
concernaient la famille! On entraîne donc
au bûcher avec soi son conjoint, ses parents,
ses enfants, ses beaux-parents... En 1602
une sorcière de Brouaumont âgée de neuf
ans envoie avec elle au bûcher son père,
sa mère, ses grand-parents, ses oncles et
ses tantes.
-Bah de deux choses: soit ils l'avaient
dénoncée, soit ils ont rien fait pour l'aider.
Dans tous les cas ça craint hein.
-Au final les procès ont pour but de diffuser
l'obéissance dans les domaines de la sexualité,
la morale, la religion... Et au début du
XVIIe, pas question de remettre en cause la
chasse au sorcières sous peine d'être accusé
de sorcellerie soi-même!
On estime qu'en Europe, il y a eu entre 60
000 et 110 000 bûchers de sorcières. D'autres
chiffres du XVIIIe-XIXe siècle évoquaient
500 000 exécutions, mais ça c'était très
exagéré.
Entre 30 et 50% des personnes jugées ont
été exécutées. Les autres, notamment ceux
qui n'avouaient rien et contre lesquels il
n'y avait pas de preuves, étaient plutôt
bannis. Du coup, ils s'exposaient à d'autres
poursuites ailleurs, parce que la vie de banni
était loin d'être facile.
A partir des années 1650, ça commence à
se calmer. Certains magistrats commencent
à refuser de condamner à mort pour sorcellerie,
disant que les femmes accusées sont peut-être
des folles qu'il faudrait plutôt traiter.
En plus l'image de la sorcière dans la littérature
et l'iconographie devient plus sympa.
Les intellectuels jouent aussi un rôle dans
cette évolution: Montaigne, Descartes,
dénoncent la chasse aux sorcières en y opposant
le principe de rationalité, Cyrano de Bergerac
déclare ne pas croire aux sorcières... En
1671, Jacques d'Autun dénonce l'attitude
des magistrats dans L'incrédulité savante
et la crédulité ignorante au sujet des magiciens
et sorciers.
-Ce. titre. Claque.
-Et il est possible que ce livre ait amené
à faire réfléchir les magistrats en question.
Les magistrats du parlement de Paris se mettent
à casser en appel des sentences prononcées
dans les provinces et Louis XIV intervient:
vers 1670 il interdit aux parlements de Rouen,
Bordeaux et Pau de poursuivre des sorcières,
et avec l'édit de 1682 la sorcellerie est
officiellement décriminalisée en France.
-Enfin!
Bien sûr, les milieux ruraux continuent de
croire aux sorcières et à la magie, tout
comme ils y croyaient déjà avant le XVe
siècle... Mais il n'y a plus de poursuites.
Pourquoi a-t-on chassé les sorcières?
Plusieurs visions et explications se sont
succédé au fil du temps.
A l'époque de la chasse aux sorcières, on
soutenait la thèse démonologique comme quoi
les femmes c'était le mal parce qu'elles
pactisaient avec le diable et tout, on commence
à connaître.
-Surtout les vieilles.
-Arrête avec les vieilles.
Pourtant, la démonologie n'est pas abordée
dans tous les procès. En Hollande, en Zélande
et en Angleterre, les procès de sorcellerie
en font très peu mention. De plus les témoignages
de sorcellerie de l'époque reprennent très
peu le mythe du sabbat ou du démon mais parlent
plutôt de la magie villageoise, c'est à
dire les maléfices lancés contre les récoltes,
le bétail, les gens...
-Le diable, c'était plutôt le délire des
inquisiteurs, mais comme les pécores ne lisaient
pas les traités de démonologie, ça leur
passait un peu au dessus.
-Dans les témoignages de personnes ayant
dénoncé des sorcières on retrouve donc
de la divination, des méthodes de guérison
pas très catholiques, des talismans protecteurs,
la mort de personnes ou de bêtes... C'est
à dire tout ce qui relève des superstitions
villageoises de l'époque.
D'ailleurs à partir du XVIIe siècle l’Église
essaie de reprendre le dessus sur ces superstitions,
en les remplaçant par le culte des saints,
avec les reliques et tout.
Mais revenons à nos moutons: la sorcellerie,
les magiciens, guérisseurs... Étaient donc
connus depuis longtemps et ne posaient pas
trop de problème jusqu'à la montée des
procès; et finalement, ce n'était pas
le lien entre les sorcières et le diable
qui semblait poser problème aux villageois
qui en dénonçaient d'autres.
Au XIXe siècle, de nouvelles théories apparaissent.
Pour les historiens romantiques, comme Jules
Michelet qui a écrit La sorcière, la femme
au XVIe siècle est un pauvre être dominé
et persécuté. Il va même plus loin et pense
que le sabbat existe réellement, et qu'à
force d'être traitée en bouc émissaire,
les femmes se rebellent, les sorcières seraient
donc des contestatrices. Là ça part un peu
loin, quand on voit que pendant leurs procès
les femmes accusées de sorcellerie avaient
la plupart du temps l'air perdues, dépassées,
on a du mal à croire à cette théorie. L'égyptologue
Margaret Murray va même plus loin que Michelet
et pense que la sorcellerie existe alors réellement
et est une survivance de cultes préchrétiens,
comme le culte de Diane, auxquels croirait
encore une grande partie de la population.
Qu'est-ce qu'on en pense aujourd'hui? Qu'est-ce
qu'il se passait dans les campagnes des XVe-XVIe
siècles en même temps que la chasse aux
sorcières?
Eh bien il semblerait que la peur de la sorcellerie
aille de paire avec la diffusion de nouvelles
idées: à partir du XVe siècle dans les
villes et du XVIe dans les campagnes, l'église
s'efforce de s'ancrer davantage dans la vie
des paysans et de remplacer les superstitions
existantes. Cela passe par l'apparition du
catéchisme, et des écoles pastorales. Dans
ces écoles, on apprend l'existence du dieu
unique, en opposition au diable qu'on fait
donc rentrer dans la culture populaire!
-Et ça fait peur aux enfants!
-Qu'est-ce que t'as appris avec le prêtre
lô?
-Hérétique, au bûcher !
-Et quelle coïncidence: les enfants dont
je parlais plus tôt, qui accusent leur famille
de sorcellerie, sont justement ceux qui viennent
juste de commencer le catéchisme. Il semble
y avoir un lien de cause à effet.
-En plus ces femmes qui se prennent pour des
guérisseuses, elles font pas un peu de concurrence
à l’Église? Et puis c'est elles qui
diffusent la culture populaire aux enfants:
toutes ces superstitions et ces croyances
païennes, c'est leur faute! Au bûcher!
Allons un peu plus loin avec ce nouvel encadrement
de la société par l’Église: au XVIe
siècle, l'âge du mariage recule. C'est frustrant,
hein? Parce que les groupes de jeunes hommes
célibataires, qui étaient pas bien jojo
à l'époque, parfois violents, sont tout
perturbés et pourraient, en réaction...
Je sais pas, accuser des femmes de coucher
avec le diable par exemple.
Dans les villages où ces nouveaux modèles
de société, cette nouvelle éducation s'impose
sans problème, on n'observe pas ou peu de
bûchers. Par contre quand ça bloque, quand
les paysans sont perturbés, qu'ils trouvent
que c'était mieux avant... On observe des
accusations de sorcellerie.
Cette idée explique que les épisodes de
chasse aux sorcières soient généralement
brefs et localisés: l’Église débarque,
commence à recomposer les rôles sociaux
du village, à répandre de nouvelles idées;
-BAM! D'un coup, on voit des sorcières
partout, l'inquisition débarque et fait le
tri dans le tas.
-Et puis, bon, finalement la crise passe,
le village trouve un nouvel équilibre, et
les accusations disparaissent. Selon cette
théorie, qui est plutôt répandue de nos
jours, la chasse aux sorcières résulte donc
d'une mutation sociale des campagnes déclenchée
par l’Église.
-Donc on s'est tapé des tas de procès et
de bûchers pour une réforme scolaire mal
foutue. Bravo. BRAVO.
-Là, tu simplifies vachement, et tu utilises
des références contemporaines pour expliquer
un événement lointain, c'est pas bien, je
peux pas te laisser faire ça.
-OK, on fait des blagues depuis tout à l'heure
et tout à coup madame devient sérieuse,
je m'en vais...
-Merci d'avoir regardé cet épisode, je rappelle
que si vous n'êtes pas familiers de la chaîne
et que vous voulez approfondir le sujet j'ai
réalisé une vidéo sur l'Inquisition et
une autre sur le Sabbat;
Si vous aimez mon travail, une fois n'est
pas coutume je rappelle que vous pouvez partager
cette vidéo et aller faire un tour sur ce
charmant tipeee!
En attendant le prochain épisode palpitant:
portez vous bien
et
à bientôt!